so many people telling us that it took
them months hours days to put together
their costumes Min over here and again a
lot of the energy starts to pick up as
people get ready to go along the parade
route this is where all the fun
starts I'm Jolly Jacko he's Jolly Jacko
I don't stress oh no oh no the world is
my upbe Rodeo hey hey I'm Jolly Jacko
hey yo Jacko that's
[Music]
me so I'm building a Pokemon meet Sesame
Street intellectual property called V
friends I've been wanting to build
something like it for a long time and
then when I saw the nft thing was
starting to mature I decided to launch
the IP as an nft while equally making
videos that 99% of nfts were going to go
to zero like I'm all in on the macro be
careful of the micro Pro but now I'm
like very far along if you go to eBay
right now and type in V friends you'll
be blown away with the pins and stickers
and trading cards I'm actively building
a Marvel a Hello Kitty a Pokemon right
now I didn't really think 3 years ago
that that's what I was going to do so I
stayed very curious about a lot of
things and then I act on it but you have
to be careful to not just follow a trend
cuz you think it's a trend crypto this
cannabis that he this you see those kind
of people who are just always on to the
next thing for me I am on to the next
thing a lot but it's always fitting a
strength or something I've been thinking
about hey Vlog uh right now you can see
the team is kind of like prepping for
this big befs Halloween parade that
we're doing here it's an iconic New York
City parade we have a massive beend flow
with Crocs we've got some Crocs on that
have some jibbit on them that if it
zooms in nicely you can tell those are
vriends jibit so I'm excited about this
quite a bit this is just the behind the
scenes of like actually building an
intellectual property like this is step
by step like when you say outlandish
like I do like I'm I'm going to try
to build a Marvel Disney Pokemon Sesame
Street I mean takes 30 years these are
big things like I drew these
characters 3 years ago and now we have
like a massive float at like the biggest
New York City Halloween parade and so
it's fun and it's Challen in and it's
exciting and it's
[Music]
humbling J and I know each other
from early days very early that's the
best part of it be friends yes one of my
favorite things to do when I'm super
tired and traveling is just read the
Discord and Twitter of all of you
interacting with all of you MH it's the
best and all of these events are just
bringing more people together every time
I come to one of these we never met
before I meet new people of course it's
the whole point I believe in it so
muchow thank you so much for joining us
today we're super pumped to be here and
thank you please as first have fun and
be safe everyone who's walking please
grab the tone bag have fun happy
Halloween
[Music]
Gary vaynerchuk is one of the sponsors
of the parade this year so they are
shouting his name out there we're going
to try to get uh get him on camera let's
go back down to Roger right on 6th
Avenue Roger who do you have J now Gary
V yes sir uh big supporter of the parade
good to see you out here it's an honor
to be a part of this have friends here
it's been an unbelievable night yeah we
just got a chance to see the float go by
very cool like for a Jersey New York kid
like me to have my float go by on this
epic night that I've watched for the
last 40 years is one of the most
humbling moments of my career and W tell
me about a night like this I mean for me
just the creativity that goes into it
the spirit it truly is a New York event
it is there are certain things that like
wreak New York and and this event
absolutely is and again for an 80s baby
like me this was such an iconic event in
'90s and things of that nature and so
and just you know look the world's tough
there's a lot going on to see all the
Smiling Faces tonight has been a a
really enjoyable night Gary always a
pleasure to talking to you
pleasure